- The US economy is on pace
to grow six times faster
than the Fed predicted at
the beginning of the year,
and to completely avoid the recession
that just about every
major investment bank
predicted would happen.
Stocks are jumping with the
NASDAQ up by more than 35%.
So why does everyone seem so bumped?
It's not just that the vibes are off.
There are three big reasons
why the US is in economic expansion,
but a confidence recession
falling, real wages,
declining affordability,
and a rising imbalance
between Americans' debt and their savings.
It really is all about the numbers.
Consumer confidence is
lower than it has been
93% of the time since 1978.
That decline in confidence has a lot to do
with what's happening to American's pay.
The latest data show that
American's wages are still rising,
but by some measures they're
no longer keeping pace
to the inflation, meaning
real wages are falling.
The latest CPI Inflation report
showed real average weekly
earnings rose in November,
but had fallen in October
for the third month in a row.
US households earning
less than $71,000 a year
have seen their disposable income decline
for five straight quarters.
In addition to the stagnating wages
many Americans are seeing,
some things are getting
much more expensive.
A new study from real estate
brokerage firm, Redfin,
found that the average
monthly mortgage payment
in the US has more than
doubled since 2013,
and has risen by more
than $1,400 since 2020.
Redfin's study also found a record low
15% of homes were affordable this year,
a 42% decrease from 2022,
which had previously set the record
for lowest number of affordable homes.
Redfin defines a listing as affordable
if the estimated monthly mortgage payment
is no more than 30% of the
local county's median income.
Childcare payments have
also jumped significantly.
According to internal
data from Bank of America,
the average childcare
payment per household
has risen by more than 30% since 2019.
And buying a car has also reached
record levels of unaffordability.
Car shopping website, Edmunds,
found that a record high
percentage of consumers
who finance their vehicle
were paying more than $1,000 a month.
Falling affordability and
the decline in real wages
have led to Americans taking
on billions more in debt
while putting less in their savings.
The US personal savings
rate hit 3.8% in October.
That's not only below
the long-term average,
it's less than half.
According to government
data going back to 1959,
Moody's also found that Americans earning
between 21,000 and around $71,000 a year
have had a negative personal savings rate
for five quarters in a row.
So not only have those
folks been unable to save
for more than a year,
most of them have been spending more money
than they're bringing in.
That imbalance is showing
up in debt levels.
US household debt balances
increased by $228 billion
in the third quarter alone
according to the New York Fed.
And after credit card balances rose
by a record $154 billion
in the third quarter.
Americans now have more than $1 trillion
of credit card debt for
the first time ever.
We're also seeing a significant
increase in Americans
who can't pay off their loans.
Defaults on consumer loans
rose to the highest level
in more than 10 years last quarter.
Put all of this together,
and you can see why even
with falling inflation,
booming stock prices,
and a strong job market,
Americans aren't feeling all
that confident these days.